so i have to be honest the last time i
felt this unnerved while watching a
movie
was when i was watching your amazing
film hereditary
how do you pick these awesome rolls
oh well that's good i think
um definitely good definitely good
i mean i don't know in a way i think
the jobs kind of choose me in a way i
mean ultimately i agree to do them but
it's almost like
when i read it and i feel it and see it
there's just like an immediate knowledge
that i have to
do it and it's this experience that is
meant to be you know
wow not every job is like that but the
ones that really
like sit with me in a poignant way do do
have that kind of quality
yeah and what was it about this
character and this story that just
really hit you that you knew you
immediately needed to be a part of this
well first of all i'm a massive charlie
kaufman fan i think
he's just an incredible filmmaker um
and i had a couple of kind of close
calls almost working with with him in
the past and it never happened and then
i
got a call saying he wanted to talk to
me about
about a film he was making so i i read
the script
the script is i hadn't read the novel
and i still haven't read the novel
because i like to steal
screenplay um and not kind of muddy up
the information that i'm kind of
allowed to know um and then i chatted
with him and he it's just so he's
so unashamedly out there right it's just
really very bonkers but
that's the initial response and then in
talking to him
and re-reading it's just the most
incredibly delicate complex
world that he has knit together and
um it just was really freeing as an
actor because
there were no rules everything was very
changeable
um and
yeah i mean it's hard to talk in that
way because the context of it is not
something you really
initially understand right so um
yeah but it's it's deep and it's funny
and it's just so many things i think
he's so wonderful with
the tone of it he's created this
incredible tone and
um it's just so interesting to watch
something so original you know
and to be part of something absolutely
and i also want to say congratulations
on your emmy nomination for best
supporting actress for unbelievable
um how did it feel to get recognition
for your work in that miniseries
oh god it's it's amazing i mean
um i just
love that unbelievable is still you know
the conversation
is continuing people still talk about it
and still being recognized and
it's a really important conversation
that should be ongoing
um and yeah i'm just happy for the show
to be honest i was really thrilled
yeah i just even people in my life like
it really affected people
so it was it was important to have that
out there so i'm so happy it was made
um you know so many of us are at home so
many of us are spending time with our
families
uh what is time at home than like for
you and your family
oh god i loved it i'm in sydney in
australia and it's
um you know we're not in lockdown
anymore
but um i i actually flew home i hadn't
started shooting with
guillermo del toro in town
and then we shut down and um i flew home
and i my life my life's quite fast-paced
and just to be able to stay at home with
no obligations for that period of time
with my
husband and kids was delicious i loved
it i know it's been
horrible for so many people but i just
really appreciated the slow
nature of it yeah and is your husband
doing better
believe that was fun too sorry is your
husband doing better
yes thank you for asking okay good okay
um okay so any updates on
nightmare alley like you're saying i
love everything guillermo del toro so i
cannot wait to see this one are you guys
do you know when you're shooting again
yeah i mean yes i'm a huge fan of his as
well um
they already have shot maybe half of the
film and um
so i am heading back to canada
very soon um and beginning in september
oh that's so exciting and was this kind
of one of those scripts that you knew
you needed to be a part of as well
yeah absolutely it's garam up
oh yeah you don't send it to charlie i'm
so lucky i mean that is just
my dream all i want to do i've been
doing this for 30 years and all i want
to do
with great directors if i'm going to act
i want to make it
worthwhile and so you know a good script
there are so many elements that make it
wonderful but you just know you're in
great hands with someone like
guillermo and chad